des corps dénudés ou partiellement
couverte de tissu qui laisse peu de
place au mystère
maillot au transparent ou body painting
unité qui se conjugue au féminin comme
au masculin choquant pour les hommes
banal pour les autres pour nadia
champville docteur en sociologie jugé
différemment la nudité selon les genres
serait une approche sexiste il n'y a pas
de raison que l'on que l'on gloss à ce
point qu'on passe autant de temps à
critiquer a jugé la manière de
s'habiller et le corps des femmes dans
le carnaval alors que ça n'a jamais posé
dans ce cas autant de problèmes de voir
des hommes à moitié nue voire parfois
juste vêtue d'un string ou d'une
chaussette on attend des sommes qu'ils
aient un discours érotique sur le corps
des femmes on attend des femmes qu'elles
contrôlent les pulsions les penser que
les hommes ou sur le corps sur leur
corps l'inversé n'est pas vrai
la sociologue différencie tout de même
là me dit et des adultes de celle des
adolescentes comme cette jeune mineur
laissant apparaître un préservatif dans
son soutien gorge oui il faut pas se
tromper dans la hiérarchie des
responsabilités quand on parle de
l'hyper sexualisation des enfants on
fait des corps des filles d'abord des
objets des objets que l'on peut vendre
que l'on peut louer des objets que l'on
va vendre notamment dans dans tout ce
qui est pédopornographie dans tout dans
tous ses magasins sur papier glacé où on
offre à voir et à penser que le corps
des femmes et même des filles est un
objet que l'on peut consommer
une hyper sexualisation qui bénéficient
désormais largement de nouveaux supports
de communication
je pense que les réseaux sociaux
ont aidés ont participé à cette espèce
de vulgarisation du corps de la
sexualité et puis
une forme d'inconscience ou de je m'en
foutisme ça sort de la sphère privée
vont se mettre je la place publique et
être présente et montrer à tout le monde
ce type d'évolution qu'on a de la
société alors si c'est une évolution
peut-être un peu dangereuse parce que
jusqu'à quel point ces personnes
connaissent plus encore objet de
nombreuses critiques la nudité pendant
les jours gras ne serait donc que le
reflet d'une hyper sexualisation plus
générale de la société tout entière
reste que conjuguait une période festive
qui repousse les limites de l'interdît
ces phénomènes ne sont pas toujours sans
conséquences pour ceux qui y participent